قد يكون دونالد ترامب متهمه من قبل بعض
امتلاك مشاعر سلبيه تجاه الاجانب لكن
الحقيقه انه بات لديه صهر جديد من العالم
العربي وبالتحديد من
لبنان من هو مايكل بوليستر جامب الجديد
ولد مايكل في لبنان عام
1997 لكنه نشا في نيجيريا ويقول مقربون
منه صباح العربيه انه كاميرا على يد مربيه
نيجيريات واحب الطعام النيجر وتعلق بهذا
البلد الافريقي الذي صنعها ثروه عائلته
درس في لندن لكن حس رجل الاعمال ورثه عن
والده مسعد بولس وهو المدير العام لمجموعه
ضخمه من الشركات لكن الملك الحقيقي لتلك
الشركات هو مؤسسها مواجهه مايكل لوالدته
زهير فضول احد كبار الاثرياء المنحذرين من
بلده بيت شباب الشهيره
في طفولته
لمت بعائلته حيث قتل عدد من اقاربه في
تحطم طائره كانت تقلهم من كتونه في
افريقيا الى لبنان وكان هدفهم حينها حضور
العزاء لما ساعه عائليه اخرى يختلف مايكل
عن شقيقه عن شقيقه هو شقيقه فهو يميل الى
عالم كمان وهم يميلون الى الفن مثل
والدتهم ساره بولاس التي اسست جمعيه
للفنون المسرحيه في نيجيريا في عام 2018
التقط المصورون اول لقطه لحفظ فني ترامب
مع مايكل بولو وكان مايكل محظوظا كفايه
يتقدم بعرض الزواج للتفني من امام البيت
والدها الذي كان حينها البيت الابيض